thank you for joining us at 11 i'm bryan
loftis and i'm denise valdez so tomorrow
is the last day ccsd students and staff
will be out of class for that pause
everyone was sent home last thursday
because of a spike in covet cases and
also a shortage of staff now some
families are proactively getting tested
before returning victoria saha spent
some time at the fiesta henderson
testing site talking to parents students
and teachers
yeah we've been seeing people coming
into that in and out of that testing
garage all evening long people are
really taking advantage of the no wait
times here at fiesta henderson and many
hoping that getting by getting tested
today they'll have their results back by
wednesday morning
that has been feeling a little ill so i
want to keep it safe seventeen-year-old
tashiana clay was not taking any chances
as she gets ready to go back to school
wednesday this is too much going on and
there's a lot of kids on one small place
she was among the 2000 people getting a
covet test at fiesta henderson last week
the school district announced a five-day
pause starting friday to help alleviate
some of the stress coming from rapid
cases of covid and staffing issues i've
gotten a lot of sleep
so i've really appreciated the rest
karen bryce jones is eager to get his
son back to school only with a negative
covet test we don't want to send him
back and having risk infecting any other
students or teachers jones says while he
wished the school district did not go on
pause he feels it was a safe decision
but i'd rather have everyone get get
better as much as possible have less
disease in the schools so that when they
go back that they have less
interruptions with teachers those who
got their copin 19 test at this location
are expected to get their results back
within three days
this testing site is open saturday
through wednesday but if you do plan on
coming the testing directors do want you
to know a couple of things you do need
an appointment to come here and it's
important to remember to bring your
voucher that you get in your email
confirmed after you make that
appointment reporting from fiesta
henderson victoria saha live local now